Let's talk a little bit more
about making these T-charts.
Specifically, let's talk about
the choices you get to make.
When I'm making a T-chart, I always
want to make sure I have three values,
three x,y pairs.
And I get to choose
whatever values I want.
Let's say the equation I'm
looking at is 2x + y = 10.
And I want to make it table of values
and then I want to graph that table.
Well, let me write down some proposed
tables of values that I might
want to use.
Maybe I'd want to use x values of 0,
2, and 4.
Or maybe I'd want to use 1,000,
2,000, and 3,000.
Or maybe I want to use negative 10,
100, and 101.
I want to know which of these proposed
T-charts will be easiest to make
a graph from.
Select whichever one you think is best.